قاسم المشترك جمع وفرق بين الرئيسين
الحالي جوبيد والسابق دونالد ترامب
وزاره العدل الامريكيه بدات في اجراء
مقابلات مع العديد من الاشخاص
المرتبطين بالرئيس
كجزء من تحقيق حول الوثائق المصنفه سريه
منذ ان كان نائبا للرئيس الاسبق باراك
اوباما المجموعه تلك ضمه مساعدين سابقين
والذين شاركوا في تعبئه وغلق سجلاته
واغراضه الشخصيه يتم التعامل مع تحقيق
المرتبط بوثائق ترامب من قبل مستشار خاص
بينما كلفت وزاره العدل المدعي الفيدرالي
الاعلى في شيكاغو وهو مسؤول باداره ترامب
بفحص مساله بيضه تم استرداد ما يقرب من
300 وثيقه سريه بعضها مصنف سري للغايه من
ترامب منذ تركه منصبه في يناير 2021
في ما اكتشف محامو بيدن نحو 12 من السجلات
السريه داخل المكتب في مركز الابحاث
وابلغوا الارشيف الوطنيه الامريكيه بذلك
ازمه اخرى تشتعل حربا بين الجمهوريين
والرئيس الديمقراطي
وتتسبب في حرج سياسي كبير لبيض بعد ترامب